[Music]
this is my morning commute I get up get
ready get in a car drive to the train
station look for parking
get on a train for an hour and a half
arrive at Penn Station get another train
for five minutes and start my work is
this killing me
before you go and post that comment
telling me to move closer you need to
see that I'm not the only person doing
this this is the train station I commute
from this place is huge and yet it's
full almost every single day just as
past fall they had to rip out an entire
section of trees to make more space for
parking and it's still not always enough
according to US census data the average
American commute is nearly 30 minutes
one way a number that's been on the rise
for the last few decades in general
people are choosing to commute further
and farther than ever before and those
long grueling hours and cars on trains
or buses can take a toll on a person's
health especially when we all hate it so
very very much
if you commute or you've been on the
internet at all you've seen the articles
and maybe you've read the studies
commuting has been linked to higher
rates of obesity stress anxiety
depression higher blood pressure higher
rates of divorce neck and back problems
shorter lifespans and you get the point
commuting long distances just isn't good
for you but a lot of it comes down to
how you do it for example a Canadian
study of commuters in Montreal found
that people who walk bike or hop on a
train at a higher life satisfaction than
those with comparable commute times on
other types of transit in another study
British researchers found that people
who drive to work instead of using
public transportation are more likely to
be obese sitting in a car all day really
adds the negative effects of an inactive
lifestyle you're sitting for hours on
end and when all is said and done it's
really hard to find the time or the
motivation to exercise and that's not it
research has shown that driving alone in
particular can make you more miserable
you're alone with your thoughts for
hours
often in frustrating situations so it's
not really surprising that this is the
disaster for both your mental and
physical health yet according to a 2010
report this is exactly how 80% of
Americans commute to work every single
day
now by comparison those who take public
transportation are slightly healthier
and slightly more satisfied with life
yet we tend to be more negative about
our experience overall public transit
commuters often resent the timetables if
I don't leave work at 6 o'clock on the
dot
I won't catch the 621 if I don't catch
the 621 I have seen on the 653 and
that's the difference between me getting
home at 8:00 p.m. and me getting home at
8:45 throwing things like transfers
delays cancellations and you have a
really solid foundation for a very
stressful very annoying commute
basically none of this is looking good
for my mortality then why do so many of
us do it community has been viewed as a
source of stress but in fact it gives
people a break it's sometimes the only
hour of the day that individuals have
alone to be by themselves to think to
listen to music meaning my commute isn't
technically dead space in my day I catch
up on reading I listen to podcast I take
advantage of the alone time but I can
also get worked on when I need to the
change in communications has made
commuting an extension of the workday or
an opportunity for the individual to do
things they couldn't otherwise do it's
not just a way to go from point A to
point B in other cases where people who
live in the gig economy and so having a
home that is accessible to
transportation is far more important
than having a home which is next to your
workplace if you're not gonna have a
lifetime job let's have a lifetime home
so is my commute actually killing me
well it's certainly not the best way to
spend so much of my time and it is
exhausting but you can make the most of
it and there's something to be said
about coming home at the end of it all
[Music]
you